welcome you are about to do something
very special which is to negotiate the
future of work this video is designed to
help you know what you need to know to
navigate the software and the tools and
methods to help you be successful in
this process what you see on the screen
are a series of slides will spend more
time with some less with others or all
of them will be available to you on the
course website here's what you need to
know at the beginning once you agree to
be part of this negotiations we want you
to sign up and we want you to commit
because in the negotiations there will
be yourself and three or four other
people in appropriate roles and they'll
all be depending on you to stay through
to agreement and frankly that's how
you'll all learn what are the roles the
roles in the negotiation match key
stakeholders in society labor management
government and education and essentially
each of you will be taking on one of
these roles they'll be assigned through
the course platform and that will tell
you who you're going to represent in
figuring out the future of work now once
you're assigned to your role you'll come
to the website platform for this
negotiation that's what you see on the
screen here it again reiterates what are
the different roles in the exercise and
gives you some background about the
assignment and then for all four of the
roles there's two here and two more
you'll see some excellent ooh help you
know what you need to know to be
effective in your role you'll see
there's a next button I just checked it
that will move you on to the next screen
which is where you start to fill out
some of the key information we need
there's different universities that are
participating in this check which one
you're coming from you will be assigned
a group number which you want to assign
and then there's other demographic
information that you'll fill out on
education whether you've been a member
of a union age and other factors they're
all required except the gender item
which is optional but again
to finish filling out those different
items you'll click Next and you go on to
a screen that now asks you to tell us
about your preferences or priorities
before negotiations begins you'll see
that there's five different issues about
workforce capability all of which could
be subjects of negotiation and we want
you to rank order them from your top
priority to your second third fourth and
fifth you know ties here you have to
pick one two three four or five for each
of the five items there's also some
questions about representation about
organizational performance about
compensation and rewards and incentives
for managers as well as work family
kinds of issues all of these are
questions that indicate your priorities
going in and frankly they get you
thinking about what's at stake as you
think about the future of work finally
before we go on to the next screen in
each of the five big categories each of
which had five sub questions we want you
to rank order those in terms of what's
important in the role that you're
playing and again you'll press next and
go on to the next screen here there's a
couple of short attitude questions about
cooperation and competition again these
will be quick and they give us your
attitudes before we begin the bargaining
that's the setup now we're getting ready
to bargain you'll see that there's a
slide that tells you and a set of
materials about preparation the key
thing about preparation is to not just
think about your own priorities and
frankly your underlying interest but to
think about the priorities and the
interest what's really at stake for the
people in the other roles and so the
prep preparation materials will get you
up to speed moving through it quickly
but there's a lot here to read that will
help you in negotiations we say the
three things that are most important our
preparation preparation and preparation
just like in real estate location
location and location this time is time
that's well spent at this point now you
you've committed to bargain you've got
your role you've done your preparation
and we're ready to begin negotiations
I'm going to say a little bit about the
negotiations and then we're going to
talk about the what happens afterwards
you'll see that there's a link to the
settlement form which I'll show you in a
minute but there's also i'm sorry
there's also a page that's not on here
but that will come on your screen that
will let you print out all of your
preparation choices either in a PDF or
anna printed document so that you've got
that in front of you when it comes to
the actual bargaining i'm going to just
give you a very simple example let's say
in the opening statement and you'll all
make opening statements and this is of
course virtual negotiation so you'll be
writing it out online for the others in
your group to see the folks who are in
the workers were all might say there
ought to be more government grants for
skills training the person in the
government role may say we're willing to
provide some funding but only in areas
that are skill shortages in society
management might say yes but the grant
should be the to the employers since
they know what the skills are not just
to the individuals the education
providers say this needs to be part of
an integrated education system and so
these funds for curriculum development
ought to come to the educational
institutions so that they can provide
the new training that's needed
government may say that's all great but
we need to have a funding mechanism
let's say one cent per hour for the
people that work management as you see
here might say well we're education
providers so we should be able to get
development funds to ultimately the
management the workers and the education
providers might come together and say we
need to provide governance and insight
and input into this government
initiative and together they might then
outline what an agreement is but as you
can see there's a series of iterative
proposals and counter proposals that are
all part of the negotiations and in the
end we're not looking for a simple
sentence we
had an agreement on government funded
education we're really looking for two
or three paragraphs that says who does
what what are they agreeing to how will
be it funded and what are the outcomes
involved now we've done this many times
and it turns out this issue support for
worker training is a common issue that
people pick we want you to push the
envelope about what's needed in the
future of work so we're going to say
that at least for your first two
agreements they cannot be agreements
that are on this issue of government
funded education but on other issues
that are among the many 25 issues that
we've highlighted in five categories and
then if you want to come back to this as
part of a package great but the point is
push the envelope do something new once
you have an agreement you'll then follow
the URL to a screen that looks like what
you see here it says it's part two and
again it'll ask you what group number
you are at what institution are you
doing this and then you'll find that
there's a question about what role are
you in how many people are part of this
agreement and what were their roles so
obviously if you are an education
institution you would check management
labor and federal government and leave
education blank on question five but at
that point you go to the next screen and
this is your chance to indicate what you
actually agreed to you'll click let's
say fair treatment and a screen will
open up saying right into this what you
agreed upon this is important each of
you will be entering the agreement
separately so if there's four people in
ago she ations there'll be four entries
of the text it's perfectly okay for you
to each cut and splice the same language
but the key thing and by the way if you
put in different language that's
evidence that it might not be a very
stable agreement but the point is you
each put in your language because we
also ask you to each rate how important
is this in terms of your role and how
satisfied you are you with the process
not just the substance to get to this
agree
and this way we can hear from each of
you in the negotiations and of course
there's a space for you to say if
there's anything else that you want to
put and that completes the process
there's a link here that will let you
come back and enter a second or third
agreement and when you're done when
you're done you will have done something
very special which is you will have
negotiated an agreement about the future
of work people who are in positions of
power and authority are interested to
see what comes out of the negotiations
in this course we will try to sum up the
agreements and look for insights and
lessons around which there might be the
kind of alignment that could actually
change things in society and ensure that
the institutions of work are better
designed to serve the needs of yourself
and others in the future generations
thank you very much